by popular demand a goofy movie this is
a film I actually already talked about a
bit I did a list of the top nostalgia
critics I wouldn't review and one of
them was a goofy movie I wasn't really
sure why so many people wanted me to
review this I will say that in a sense I
was the exact wrong age to see this when
it came out I think it was just starting
to enter high school when you're
starting to enter high school you don't
want to see a Disney film with goofy in
it so keep in mind I didn't grow up with
this I actually saw it years later but
for what I saw I mean okay it's not
among one of the best Disney films or
anything but you know what for what I
could gotten I was actually kind of
pleasantly surprised the story is max
now played by a different voice actor is
forced to go on a field trip with his
father goofy the only downside is all
his friends are going to a concert and
even a possible girlfriend named Roxanne
might be there as well so while on the
trip he's constantly trying to find a
way to steer the car towards the concert
instead of on the fishing trip that his
father wants to go on so yeah kind of a
standard story but what really sets it
apart oddly enough is the connection
between the father and the son the
father just wants to be a part of his
son's life and the son of course wants
his independence this could easily be
shown through a bunch of throwaway lines
and yeah they're in there too but
actually there's a lot of quiet and dare
I even say it kind of mature moments in
this movie I mean it never goes too far
I always comes back to the fact that
it's a funny cartoon but for example
look at this opening artistically this
is a very nicely laid out movie and I
mean think about it you're doing
gooftroop the movie would you expect any
of this to be in it in fact it's
actually kind of cool to see Disney
animated some modern-day technologies
like what's the last time you saw a hot
tub in a Disney film and really they
don't take their gloves off even when
they go swimming cartoons are weird I
will say one of the downsides is that
there's very little up Pete's family
that was always my favorite part of the
show we don't even see the wife the
crazy daughter or the dog and I really
missed them they were funny but to be
fair that's not the movies focus it
really is supposed to be about the
father and son and they keep it where it
should be as long as I don't remember
too well with the exception of the
opening one I have Tim it is pretty
catchy
hey-oh
gonna sit on my gosh the song done by
the pop star at the concert is also
pretty enjoyable but mostly for awkward
corniness seems like this and even a
play down Pauly Shore I actually work
okay in the movie in the same way that
Zack Morris works in Saved by the Bell
yeah you know it's not really popular
but you know what you give it a pass
it's cute it's energized the characters
are having a lot of fun in it the
romance actually isn't that bad either
the Roxane character is actually kind of
cute and likable and the two of them
actually do share a believable chemistry
well I don't know has the shy stuttering
guy in the corner really ever gotten the
hot girl well I'll tell you no it hasn't
but a goofy movie is a very fun it's
bright and colorful it's got good stuff
for kids and it's got a couple of good
things for adults as well the jokes are
pretty clever the characters are pretty
likable is no masterpiece but I think
it's definitely worth a look
yeah